Neural network adalah kelas algoritma machine learning yang powerful
dan ada banyak jenisnya
kita nggak bisa membahas neural network secara menyeluruh
dalam video pengantar
seperti ini, di sini kita cuma akan mengidentifikasi beberapa komponen kunci
dari neural network dan alur kerja secara keseluruhan
supaya kita bisa paham bagaimana komputasi kuantum bisa berkontribusi
neural network adalah graf neuron yang saling terhubung
sebuah neuron pada dasarnya cuma sesuatu yang menyimpan sebuah angka
dan angka itu sering disebut aktivasi, seberapa
aktif atau tidaknya sebuah neuron
neuron-neuron dikelompokkan dalam beberapa layer
dan layer pertama adalah layer input
dan yang terakhir adalah layer output
di antaranya ada layer-layer yang digunakan dalam pemrosesan yang disebut
hidden layer, aktivasi dari
layer input langsung dimuat dari data yang akan dianalisis
seperti nilai kecerahan piksel dalam sebuah gambar
aktivasi hidden layer berikutnya ditentukan
oleh neuron-neuron di layer input
dan oleh bobot yang dilambangkan dengan garis yang menghubungkan semua neuron
di layer input ke semua neuron di
layer berikutnya, dengan kata lain kita menentukan aktivasi
sebuah neuron di hidden layer
dengan jumlah terbobot dari semua
aktivasi input, kita juga bisa
menerapkan bias, sebuah pergeseran
kita mungkin ingin mengaktifkan sebuah neuron
di hidden layer bukan hanya jika jumlah terbobot bernilai
positif, tapi hanya jika melampaui ambang batas yang besar
kita lalu sering menerapkan fungsi yang rumit untuk mendapatkan aktivasi
antara nol dan satu, seperti tangen hiperbolik
atau kadang berbeda, sebuah
rectified linear unit, kamu nggak perlu terlalu khawatir
tentang ini sekarang, satu-satunya hal
yang penting untuk dicatat di sini tentang fungsi-fungsi ini
adalah bahwa mereka non-linear
sehingga jaringan secara keseluruhan mengandung komponen linear
maupun non-linear
jumlah terbobot aktivasi yang sama, kali ini
dimulai dari aktivasi
hidden layer pertama dengan bobot yang baru
merambat ke hidden layer berikutnya
ini berlanjut sampai layer terakhir yang merupakan output
layer output punya neuron yang sesuai dengan
kategori-kategori, dan aktivasinya memberitahu kita
seberapa yakin jaringan tentang klasifikasinya
jadi kategori output dalam analisis gambar bisa berupa
anjing, kucing, hamster, dan sebagainya
dan aktivasi 0,95 pada
neuron anjing menunjukkan tingkat keyakinan yang tinggi bahwa
gambar itu adalah anjing, kamu mungkin memulai neural network-mu
dengan sekumpulan bobot acak
dan bias, atau dari konfigurasi awal yang wajar dan sudah diketahui
tapi kemudian idenya adalah untuk memeriksa
seberapa baik neural network-mu mengklasifikasikan sesuatu
dan memperbaikinya, kita menggunakan fungsi cost untuk menggambarkan
seberapa jauh neural network kita menyimpang dari
klasifikasi yang benar, ini melibatkan pengambilan
selisih antara nilai aktual sebuah gambar
misalnya nilai satu pada neuron
untuk anjing dan nol pada semua neuron output lainnya
dan nilai yang diprediksi
kita jumlahkan semua kategori
sehingga kita melacak bukan hanya apakah kategori yang benar
paling teraktivasi, tapi kita juga bisa
melacak apakah aktivasi yang salah berkurang
kita jumlahkan semua contoh dalam training set kita
dan dapatkan sebuah cost, kita kemudian
memvariasikan parameter seperti bobot di setiap layer
antara semua neuron dan bias pada semua neuron itu
rutinitas optimasi klasikal digunakan
untuk mencari minimum lokal dalam fungsi cost
jika tidak ada yang dilakukan untuk mengurangi kompleksitas ini
kamu bisa bayangkan betapa
astronomisnya ruang parameter yang kita buat di sini
bayangkan sebuah neural network yang dirancang untuk menganalisis gambar dengan
hanya seribu piksel, neural network ini mungkin punya seribu
neuron input, hanya satu hidden layer
dan output biner seperti kucing atau anjing
ini adalah kasus yang paling sederhana
dan tetap saja berkorespondensi dengan seribu dikali seribu
atau satu juta bobot antara layer input dan hidden layer
dan dua ribu lagi antara
hidden layer dan output layer
mungkin juga sekitar seribu atau
lebih bias, jadi neural network sederhana ini akan berkorespondensi
dengan lebih dari satu juta parameter, tapi kalau mau jujur
algoritma modern biasanya memang membuat penyederhanaan
dalam neural network klasikal
dan ada banyak bidang yang didedikasikan untuk membuat minimisasi ini
bisa dilakukan dan bahkan efisien
tapi faktanya tetap bahwa ini adalah masalah
berdimensi sangat tinggi
dan melatih sebuah neural network
bisa sangat memakan waktu
dan mahal, sebuah quantum neural network atau QNN
bekerja dengan pertama-tama memuat data input
kemudian menerapkan quantum circuit
yang berkorespondensi dengan bobot antar layer
dan terakhir sebuah layer pengukuran
beberapa poin penting tentang ini, data
loading dan pembobotan adalah operasi linear
tapi pengukurannya bersifat non-linear
jadi seperti dalam neural network klasikal, kita punya
komponen linear maupun non-linear
selain itu weight circuit
masih punya parameter variasional
jadi masih ada minimisasi klasikal yang harus dilakukan
tentu saja ini baru menyentuh permukaan dari quantum neural
network, tapi kami harap kamu terus belajar tentang aplikasi
dari quantum neural network
dan aplikasi quantum machine learning lainnya
bersama IBM Quantum